one of the most illogical and outdated
pieces of British law that currently
exists is the ban on cannabis now a
mother is urging the government to allow
her six-year-old son to be treated with
the drug for a rare form of epilepsy
Alfie Bingley suffers up to 30 fits a
day but his seizures were cutting number
and severity when he was treated with
the cannabis oil in the Netherlands but
ridiculously his mum faces a 14 year
jail sentence if she gives Alfie the oil
in Britain what is this poor mother to
do the war on drugs has failed it's time
to legalize cannabis from medicinal
purposes but also for recreational use
it will help the sick raise taxes
undercut criminal gangs and keep people
safe what's not to like magic I'm glad
you made this raise the subject and I
agree with you I think that this case of
little Alfie is really heartbreaking and
it's very frustrating to know that there
is a solution available that is not
being offered here just because of I
think outdated attitudes and bureaucracy
I don't think we should be too
dismissive about concerns about cannabis
but I think a lot of them are related to
it means well at the underworld you know
this idea that it leads on a downward
spiral to harder and more dangerous
drugs I think there's lots of evidence
in countries where it is regulated that
actually that doesn't happen I've just
come back from California where it's now
outstripping agriculture as milk and
dairy as as one of the largest
contributors the economy and in the u.s.
when nine states have legalized it the
medicinal cannabis market is worth more
than two billion dollars so the
potential is huge but I just want to
show you what Theresa May said about
Alfie's case in the comments I think I
know that the sympathies of the members
across the house of with Alfie and his
family as he's undergoing treatment and
of course people with chronic pain and
debilitating illnesses we recognize will
always look to alleviate their symptoms
but we do need to ensure that if we are
going to allow if medicines are going to
be permitted to be used that they have
been through the most rigorous testing
that they we apply the most rigorous
standards before those drugs are used
this seems like a good moment to mention
vaginas because I don't know if any of
you saw the story
I don't know if any of you saw the story
this week but these vagina measures that
have been widely used on women who given
birth to treat incontinence have not
been properly tested and yet they've
been used on women and the idea that
cannabis where so much research has been
done that thought is being talked about
them as a potential legal substance for
so long and we're depriving this child
of something that could help him and
quite happily inserting these untested
measures into women so I feel that
there's a real tough time can we talk
about why it's not legalized and the
reason is that cannabis is made up of
four hundred different chemicals before
anything in this country is legalized
for medicinal use the chemicals have to
be pure single chemicals because what
you have to do is monitor the effect
that you have to be able to monitor the
effect that the drug has on you and and
that's that's why it is not leaking
that's cuz you're also good canvas has
more carcinogens than tobacco in it but
you just mentioned California they're
one of the biggest studies on cannabis
in the entire world has just been
conducted out there it's the national
academy of science engineering and
medicine and it says it is it is warning
of the very aggressive downsides of some
kind of issues they're talking about
schizophrenia schizophrenia psychosis
respiratory problems people taking
cannabis have more car crashes than ever
average person now while I get that
Alfie's parents are devastated about
this I get it if I had a child I'd want
to give it anything out there that was
possible but we can't you know by
legalizing something you are saying it's
not dangerous and we can't say that
about cannabis because we know it can be
very different there's so many
assumptions in what you just said so
let's start with this one by legalizing
something you're saying it's not Dana
that's simply not true
nobody's saying that alcohol is not
dangerous nobody's saying is that
tobacco hold on so we're talking about
regulating an industry the studies
you've cited the this is it this is why
so incredibly frustrating for me because
the debate around cannabis and its
legalization and regulation is so
culturally bias it's unbelievable
studies prove now Lancet in 2010 a
peer-reviewed medical journal
basically demonstrated that by all
criteria that you could possibly
consider tobacco
alcohol are far worse for you are far
more dangerous for society previous far
more crime than the legalization of
cannabis would as for road traffic
incidents where it's where's where it
has been legalized in Colorado State in
Washington Washington states in Oregon
and in Alaska they found not only did
team use of cannabis remain the same
remain the second crime went down and
ranging up just arguing fighting stance
at each other omnia and trying to argue
that sure I mean what is clear about
this country is that we've got a drugs
policy we've got what there's no please
just let somebody else say something
what we've seen for years I'm a cannabis
has been in use by many many people in
this country for years and actually that
that brings the law into disrepute
really because actually there's ignored
and even the police now ignored watch
what I would say to our fees mummies you
can obtain this do it no one's in the
ignition I've got a mate at the moment
who is suffering I've got a mate who's
been diagnosed with cancer who he's
taking liquid cannabis every day because
he believes it will be we should
encourage people to break the law also
she she met child services may get
involved it you know the problem is the
law and and I really feel for her and
actually the problem is that she could
face 14 years in jail for treating
anyone was put into jail for your hand
of his imagine it just doesn't when was
the last time children were taken away
from parents for drug consumption that
is a danger
it won't happen and so we really like to
disrespect the laws that was the cops
turn a blind eye Michelle come on you
create so I am very anti recreational
drugs for personal reasons I don't like
them but I've spent a lot of time
looking into cannabis and I've reached
the conclusion that actually it should
be legalized now firstly to make it
legal for medicine traditional purposes
that's not a change to law it's a
rescheduling of the drug to move it from
schedule one to schedule two that's the
first thing that could happen very
simply and very easily to allow that
drug to remain illegal for street use
for example but legal for medicinal
that's the first thing I think should
happen and cases like Alfie etc just you
know demonstrate that again to me when
it comes to recreational use one of the
challenges and I've had personal
experience of somebody that's had very
bad mental health issues because of
cannabis use but the type of cannabis
that he was using was skunk it was a
very very potent strong form of cannabis
if you legalized cannabis you could
actually have controls around
simplifying it essentially the
ingredients of cannabis you could apply
taxation to air on a gradual level so
just fair with me so you could taxi a
gradual level in the way of alcohol so
the stronger and more potent the
cannabis the higher the price the higher
the taxation the higher the price that
you could essentially create like a if
you think if you got Shandy at one level
of alcohol and then you've got vodka or
tequila or whatever at the other end you
could have like a sliding scale the
lowest person C of cannabis been you
know cheaper and therefore much
accessible to two people to use so I
think that adults should be able to use
cannabis for recreational choice if
their wish and it's a really interesting
thing to a think tank or volte-face volt
pass which looks into this and they are
absolutely banging the drum for this and
if you read some of their stuff is
fascinating and they've changed my view
on this and reading of the bill is
tomorrow yeah honor Labour MP Paul Flynn
proposed a bill its second reading for
medicinal purposes called the
legalization of cannabis medicine all
purposes bill is read tomorrow and long
known at lamb who was quite a good
health minister by all accounts may the
very point you've made about the dangers
of not knowing what's in the drug if it
remains illegal whereas by regulating it
let's just hear what you have to say
this is Ed let's hear what the normal
man have to say if you're buying on in a
criminal market you have no idea what
you're buying you have no idea of the
potency of what you're buying how
dangerous it is it's so much safer
it protects young people so much more if
we can regulate it in a sensible and
rational way now alcohol and tobacco are
both bad for adolescents and people that
are still developing
likewise with cannabis but there's no
proven long-term effect on adults when
they consume
point for angels but the point about
lead does anybody actually believe round
this table that if you legalize canvas
or any other drug that the drug dealers
are going to be suddenly become model
citizens overnight they are not because
what's going to happen if you if you if
the government starts selling it if we
start taxing it the drug dealers are
gonna be there and they're gonna
undercover guys and they're gonna bring
stuff in it that they have now and the
dangers will still be that we have a
precedent for that no of course I don't
you want to come back with something but
we have a press it on that and that is
prohibition and at the end of the day
when alcohol was banned crime spiraled
out of control and when Prohibition was
lifted it was brought back into control
again crime never went away but it is
say never went away but it certainly
reduced when you when you pull the rug
from under the feet of the gangsters I
just feel this is a bit of a false
comparator because then we're comparing
cannabis to alcohol and other drugs but
we're talking about cannabis for
medicinal use and Carol you know you
raised the fears about side effects we
should be comparing cannabis for
medicinal use to other drugs that are
used to treat health conditions many of
which have extremely dangerous and
debilitating side effects and when we
use substances for medicinal purposes we
accept that they do have side effects
and they cause other health health risk
that's the balance think about
chemotherapy you know why and how
damaging that is to your help now
sometimes you need to be able to conduct
a rational cost-benefit analysis of what
you can get from a drug versus the
course then that's what we should be
doing we will if it's regulated